.
- À partir du moment où on est
capable de savoir d'où l'on
vient, on est capable de savoir
beaucoup mieux où on va...
- Jacques Lacoursière avait
à coeur l'histoire du Québec
et c'est avec passion qu'il l'a
racontée. Son ami et éditeur,
l'ex-ministre de la Culture
Denis Vaugeois se souvient.
DENIS VAUGEOIS, éditeur et ami
de Jacques Lacoursière
- Ah! Écoutez, j'ai pleuré!
J'ai pleuré parce que..
on est... on se tient depuis
1959. En 59, je l'ai eu
comme étuiant à l'école normale.
- D'abord, c'est une histoire
qui est assez longue, c'est
comme toutes les histoires.
- Né à Shawinigan,
dès le début des années 60,
Jacques Lacoursière partage
avec le public son voyage
dans le temps à la radio
et à la télévision.
Conteur extraordinaire et grand
vulgarisateur, cet autodidacte
va contribuer à changer
certaines perceptions.
ÉRIC BÉDARD, historien
- C'est un homme qui avait
le sens du récit, un homme
qui voulait aussi une histoire
du Québec rassembleuse.
- Duplessis, vous savez,
il savait toujours pour
qui nos parents avaient voté.
Pour ceux qui avaient décidé
d'immigrer au nouveau monde...
- Sa série "Épopée en Amérique",
réalisée par Gilles Carle,
pour Télé-Québec, a fait école.
- J'y dois le jour, Gérald!
- Auparavant, son travail pour
la série "Duplessis" diffusée
à Radio-Canada a marqué
toute une génération.
ANDRÉ CHAMPAGNE, historien
- C'est vraiment, là, un grand
communicateur, un passionné,
mais quelqu'un qui considérait
que l'histoire doit être
transmise à tout le monde.
Et puis, il nous disait toujours
une chose : "Essayez d'étonner!"
- Si on a mangé
le coeur du père Brébeuf...
- Jacques Lacoursière a publié
plus d'une vingtaine de livres
et de nombreux articles.
Son oeuvre en cinq volume
intitué "Histoires populaires
du Québec" s'est écoulée
à près de 150 000 exemplaires.
- La force de Lacoursière,
c'est de retourner aux sources
en s'aidant éventuellement
des travaux existants,
mais en allant plus loin,
en se les appropriant.
- Monsieur Jacques Lacoursière.
(applaudissements)
- Maintes fois récompensé,
le jour de son décès à 89 ans,
le premier ministre du Québec
lui a rendu hommage.
Ses lecteurs se souviendront
longtemps de cette historien
qui a su si bien préserver
la mémoire du Québec.
- L'armée britannique vient
de partir et c'est ici que
les soldats jouaient au cricket.
(applaudissement)
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪